is the new iPhone 14 pro really that  much better than the 13 Pro well the  first thing we notice is that the space  black color is way darker especially on  the sides now of course that's a  preference but what isn't is the much  faster 5G and LTE speeds with that I saw  a huge difference in outdoor brightness  and of course that new Dynamic Island  looks cool it's not a notch anymore has  a lot of software features and that  stands out but what I like even more so  is the always-on display I was also  blown away by how much better the  speakers are  [Music]  now with some downsides we have no more  Sim slots that means you can't easily  swap that around so I don't know why  Apple had to do that and that the  dynamic Island Cuts more so into your  video which can be more distracting  overall it is a nice upgrade most of  these features are just luxury you guys  let me know your thoughts in the  comments